und ich begrüße den Kölner
Politikwissenschaftler und
amerika-experten Thomas Jäger guten
Morgen
einen schönen guten Morgen Herr Bade
silensky ist also nach Washington
geflogen nicht nach Brüssel es gibt viel
zu besprechen zu diesem Thema zu dieser
Reise fangen wir damit mal an was sagt
uns das das ist Washington war
nun die Vereinigten Staaten sind der
wichtigste Unterstützer der Ukraine und
auch derjenige der am stabilsten steht
wenn wir die großen Staaten der
Europäischen Union betrachten
Deutschland Frankreich da hat man doch
immer wieder das Gefühl dass die
Regierung Wanken und versuchen
möglicherweise doch in irgendwelche
Kompromisse mit Russland zu gelangen
Großbritannien steht so wie die USA
ziemlich stabil in der militärischen
Unterstützung der finanziellen
Unterstützung und deswegen lag es auf
der Hand das Präsident selenski nach
Washington fährt wenn er seine erste
Auslandsreise macht
gerade gesagt Washington steht fester an
der Seite der Ukraine als die
Europäische Union obwohl die Europäische
Union viel näher dran ist und die
Ukraine ja eher ein Problem für Europa
ist als für die USA nun hat Joe Biden ja
auch gesagt die USA haben bisher knapp
22 Milliarden Dollar bereitgestellt und
deshalb wundert es ja auch gar nicht
dass silenski für diese erste
Auslandsreise seit Beginn des Krieges
Washington ausgesucht hat und beiden hat
das Treffen genutzt um weitere
Versprechen zu machen zum Beispiel die
Lieferung des
patriot-flugabwehrsystems wo sich
Deutschland zum Beispiel ja sehr
zurückhaltend hatte
ja es gab ja aus Deutschland den
Vorschlag ein patriot-system in Polen zu
stationieren nachdem in Polen eine
Rakete eingeschlagen ist und die
polnische Regierung hat dann sozusagen
judogriff gemacht und hat gesagt mal
gucken wie weit die deutschen gehen wir
sagen stellt das doch nicht in Polen auf
sondern in der Ukraine und da kam sofort
nein nein das werden wir nicht tun und
das ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür wie
eben unterschiedlich das riesig die
Risiko Abschätzung ist nun muss man dazu
sagen
dass auch die Vereinigten Staaten das
Patrick System erst jetzt liefern obwohl
die Ukraine schon lange im Prinzip seit
dem ersten Tag Flugabwehr anfordert aus
gutem Grund wie man sieht denn sonst
wäre die kritische Infrastruktur des
Landes nicht zerbrummt worden von
Russland und das Russland das als
Eskalation bezeichnet ist freilich ein
Witz denn ein Abwehrsystem kann nur
derjenige als Eskalation bezeichnen der
meint ist ein Recht auf die militärische
Ohnmacht sein dann Nachbarstaates hat
zalensky hat den Washington ja auch
betont dass es noch mehr brauche und das
ist noch länger Hilfe brauche und dass
man Militärhilfe dass man auf
Militärhilfe angewiesen sei und die
nicht abreißen dürfe ist dieser Besuch
jetzt bei beiden auch zu werten als
Erfolg für selenski das sind das
zugestanden wird
ja und das war ja vorher schon deutlich
geworden die Unterstützung steht und sie
muss auch stehen denn bisher ist es ja
so gewesen dass es auch in Europa immer
hieß ja wir unterstützen die Ukraine
aber zum Beispiel nicht direkt mit
Panzern sondern da werden alte
sowjetische Panzer aus Griechenland aus
der Slowakei in die Ukraine verbracht
und diese Staaten bekommen dann eben aus
Deutschland etwa den Leopard 2 und das
ganze begründet damit na ja da können
die Ukraine mit umgehen aber irgendwann
äh sind die Ersatzteile und die Munition
für die alten sowjetischen Waffen all
und können nicht nachproduziert werden
das heißt also es gibt noch einen
paradoxen Effekt den Präsident Putin
hier ausgelöst hat nicht nur dass er
durch diesen Angriffskrieg die Ukraine
nun wirklich
in eine West Orientierung
gedrängt hat sondern die Ukraine wird
sich je länger der Krieg andauert auch
umso mehr mit Waffen aus NATO starten
rüsten müssen weil es für die anderen
keine Munition mehr gibt und insofern
werden wir im nächsten Jahr sicher
beobachten das genau das einsetzt und
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte zunehmend
Waffen aus NATO-Staaten und die
entsprechende Munition dazu bekommen
silensky hat in den Gesprächen die
Bedeutung dieser Hilfen noch auf eine
höhere Ebene gehobene gesagt das Geld
sei keine Wohltätigkeit es sei eine
Investition in die globale Sicherheit
und Demokratie mit der er die höchst
verantwortungsvolle Art hat umzugehen
und dem Weg dem erfolgen möchte die
Republikaner hatten ja zuletzt
angedeutet bei den Ukraine helfen auf
die Bremse treten zu wollen ist das noch
ein Thema jetzt in Washington oder sind
jetzt alle Demokraten und Republikaner
auf Seiten der Ukraine
nein es gibt bei den Republikanern eine
deutliche Minderheit die diese Hilfen
ablehnt also bei der letzten Abstimmung
waren es 57 Abgeordnete im
Repräsentantenhaus also so etwa ein
Viertel der Abgeordneten das mögen im
nächsten Repräsentanten Haus wenn es am
3 Januar zusammen dritten paar mehr sein
aber es reicht nicht um eine Mehrheit zu
bekommen und diese Hilfen zu verhindern
und das was viele Republikaner mit den
Hilfen verbunden haben und das verbindet
sich mit dem Begriff Blankoscheck das
ist dass man eine Kontrolle darüber
haben will wie das Geld ausgegeben wird
also der Satz von Kevin McCartney wird
ständig so interpretiert es gibt weniger
Geld das hat er nicht gesagt er hat
gesagt es gibt das Geld nicht mehr ohne
Kontrolle und in dem neuen Paket in
diesen 45 Milliarden Dollar sind deshalb
auch eine ganze Reihe Million ich glaube
es sind zweieinhalb etwa für Kontrollen
eingesetzt mit dem man wissen wollte was
geschieht eigentlich endlich mit dem
Geld aber es wird so sein dass eine
größere Minderheit der Republikaner im
Parlament dagegen stimmen wird das kann
die Regierung beiden aushalten sie wird
für diese Hilfen eine Mehrheit bekommen
in beiden kann man das Hauses
gehört an dieser Stelle der Diskussion
ja auch ins Spiel gebracht das ist bei
dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine nicht nur um
das Schicksal der Ukraine gehe er sagte
der Kampf würde definieren in welcher
Welt unsere Kinder und Enkelkinder leben
werden und dann deren Kinder und deren
Enkelkinder also er warnte ein
russischer Angriff gegen Verbündete sei
nur eine Frage der Zeit und allein
deshalb müsse die Welt müssen Amerika
der Ukraine helfen
und damit hat er völlig Recht und das
ist eigentlich das was man in Europa
verstehen müsste und was viele
Regierungen in der Europäischen Union
offensichtlich nicht verstehen das ist
ein ordnungskonflikt der gerade
ausgetragen wird zwischen dem
Ordnungsmodell der Europäischen Union in
dem sich die europäischen Staaten
zusammengeschlossen haben und zwar auch
diejenigen die in eine imperialistische
Vergangenheit haben Großbritannien frank
war dabei ist nicht dabei wer weiß wie
es kommt aber auch Frankreich und
Deutschland diese Staaten haben ja eine
imperialistische Vergangenheit und das
was gesagt wurde ist das Projekt das
einzelne Nationalstaaten Europa
dominieren das lassen wir fallen wir
schließen uns zusammen und versuchen
gemeinsam unsere Interessen
international vertreten zu können und
Russland sagt nein das Gegenteil ist der
russische Imperialismus der darauf
abhebt Europa zu dominieren und das ist
das was Russland im dezember 2021 offen
vorgeschlagen hat
Vertragsentwürfe vorgelegt hat wo es
darum geht die Ukraine und Belarus nun
wirklich zu beherrschen in
osteuropäischen Raum militärisch zu
dominieren in dem dort alle fremden
Truppen abziehen müssen und letztlich
dann die Hebel anzusetzen um Westeuropa
unter Druck zu setzen deswegen hat man
ja Deutschland was die Energie angeht
abhängig gemacht hatte das mit Italien
gemacht das alles ging nicht auf weil es
anders kam als ich Präsident Putin die
Welt in seiner Vorstellung ausgemalt hat
Thomas Jäger vielen Dank für den
Augenblick wir werden gleich nachdem wir
die Rede von selinski gehört haben noch
einmal weiter darüber sprechen aber
erstmal vielen Dank dass Sie für uns da
sind ja also Sie haben es mittlerweile
ja gemerkt das war nicht geplant diese
Sendung die wir Ihnen jetzt gerade hier
zeigen
zielensky hat unserer Zeit in der
vergangenen Nacht um 3 Uhr morgens im
US-Kongress gesprochen und das wollten
wir auch ihnen nicht zumuten dass wir
etwas derartig wichtiges um drei Uhr
nachts senden deshalb blenden wir es
heute morgen ab 9 Uhr und deshalb
verschieben sich die Dokumentationen die
ausgedruckt sind und auf diese sich
möglicherweise ja gefreut haben um etwa
eine knappe Stunde um 50 Minuten aber es
geht ja nichts verloren es wird alles
gesendet was wir vorhatten hören Sie
jetzt aber die Rede des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selensky vor dem US-Kongress
in Washington
Liebe Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner in
allen Bundesstaaten Städten und
Gemeinden
alle die die Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit
schätzen
die genauso hochhalten wie wir Ukraine
in all unseren Städten und in jeder
einzelnen Familie ich hoffe meine Worte
der Hochachtung und des
dankesklingen in allen amerikanischen
Herzen nach Frau Vizepräsidentin ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen für Ihre
Bemühungen bei der Unterstützung der
Ukraine Frau Parlamentspräsidentin
sie waren mutig und haben die Ukraine
mitten im Krieg besucht vielen Dank
dafür es war eine große Ehre
vielen Dank
es ist für mich ein großes Privileg hier
zu sein verehrte Kongressabgeordnete
Vertreter beider Parteien die auch Kiew
besucht haben
hochgeschätzte
Kongressabgeordnete und Senatoren bei
der Parteien die die Ukraine besuchen
werden davon bin ich überzeugt sie
werden in Zukunft kommen
verehrte Vertreter der Diaspora
present in die ich hier im Haus anwesend
sind und überall im Lande wohnen
verirrte Journalisten es ist für mich
eine große Ehre hier vor dem
amerikanischen Kongress zu sprechen
an Ihre Adresse und die Adresse
alarmekaner trotz aller Widrigkeiten und
Untergangsszenarien ist die Ukraine
nicht gefallen die Ukraine ist gesund
und munter
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
und das ist für mich ein guter Grund
mit Ihnen
unseren ersten gemeinsamen Sieg zu
teilen wir haben Russland eine
Niederlage bereitet im Kampf um die
Herzen der Welt
haben keine Angst und niemand in der
Welt sollte Angst haben die Ukraine
haben diesen Sieg errungen und er gibt
uns Mut und das inspiriert die ganze
Welt
wie Amerikaner haben diesen Weg errungen
und deshalb ist es ihnen auch gelungen
die Weltgemeinschaft zu einem zum
Schutze von Freiheit und des
Völkerrechts die Europäer haben diesen
Sieg errungen und deshalb ist Europa
jetzt auch stärker und unabhängiger denn
je die russische pyrannei hat
Kontrolle über uns verloren
[Applaus]
und sie wird niemals wieder unser Denken
beeinflussen aber trotzdem müssen wir
alles tun was notwendig ist um
sicherzustellen dass die Länder des
globalen Südens auch an derartigen Sieg
erringen
ich denke eins ist wichtig
die Russen haben nur eine Chance frei zu
sein wenn sie den Kreml auch in ihren
Herzen und in ihrem Verstand eine
Niederlage bereiten
[Applaus]
aber der Kampf geht weiter und wir
müssen den Kreml auf dem Schlachtfeld
schlagen ja bei dieser Schlacht geht es
nicht nur um Gebiete
grüßen oder jenen Tal Europas es geht
nicht nur um das Leben in die Freiheit
und die Sicherheit der Ukraine oder
anderer Länder bei den russland versucht
sie zu erobern dieser Kampf wird
bestimmen in welcher Welt unsere Kinder
und Enkelkinder leben werden und dann
auch deren Kinder und Enkelkinder
er wird definieren ob es eine Demokratie
geben wird für die Ukraine für die
Amerikaner und für alle dieser
Krieg diese Schlacht kann nicht
eingefroren werden oder aufgeschoben
werden man kann sie auch nicht
ignorieren in der Hoffnung dass der
Ozean oder irgendwas anderes Schutz
bieten wird von den USA bis hin nach
China von Europa nach Lateinamerika und
von Afrika nach Australien ist die Welt
einfach zu starke verwoben und Zuschauer
voneinander
abhängige als das jemand bei Seite
treten kann und gleichzeitig auch sich
sicher fühlen kann wenn ein derartiger
Kampf anhält
unsere beiden Nationen sind Verbündete
in dieser Schlacht und das nächste Jahr
wird ein Wendepunkt sein das weiß ich es
wird der Punkt sein
wokanischer Mut und amerikanische
Entschlossenheit die Zukunft unserer
gemeinsamen Freiheit garantieren müssen
die Freiheit der Menschen die für ihre
Werte eintreten
meine Damen und Herren
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner gestern
war ich ich nach Washington DC gekommen
bin an der Front in unserer Stadt Mahmut
in unserer Festung im Osten der Ukraine
im Don Bass das russische Militär und
die russischen Söldner haben
seit Mai angegriffen Tag und Nacht haben
sie Mahmut angegriffen aber was muss
leistet niederstand
[Applaus]
haben 70.000 Menschen in wachmutsche
gelebt und Jetzt leben nur noch ein paar
Zivilisten dort jederzeit gutes ist
blutgetränkt Kanonen Donner jede Stunde
die schützenkreben im dornbase zu wächst
mehrmals am Tag den Hantel und es gibt
eine heftige Schlacht sogar im Nahkampf
aber der ukrainische Don Bass steht
[Applaus]
die Russen nutzen alles wirklich alles
was sie haben gegen Mahmut
und andere unserer wunderschönen Städte
die Besatzer haben ein erheblichen
Vorteil was die Artillerie anbelangt wir
haben auch einen Vorteil bei der
Munition sie haben sehr viel mehr
Raketen und Flugzeuge als wir je hatten
das stimmt aber unsere
Verteidigungskräfte halten stand
und
wir alle sind stolz auf sie die
russische Taktik ist primitiv sie
brennen alles was Sie sehen Lieder und
zerstören es sie schicken
Schlägertruppen an die Frauen und
richtigen stresslinge in den Krieg sie
haben alles gegen uns in die Schlacht
geworfen genauso wie die andere türenei
die in der Ardennen Offensive alles
aufbrachte gegen die freie Welt genau
wie die mutigen amerikanischen soll
Daten die ihre Linien hielten und die
Truppen von Hitler
Weihnachten 1944 bekämpft nur die
mutigen orkanischen Soldaten machen das
gleiche gegenüber putinstruppen in
dieser Weihnachtszeit
die Ukraine hält ihre Stellungen und
wird sich nie ergeben
[Applaus]
hier ist also die
frontie die
sehr grausam vorgeht auf der einen Seite
und das Leben der freien Menschen auf
der andere und ihre Unterstützung ist
wenn erscheint aber Leute nicht nur um
die Stellung zu halten in diesem Fall
auseinandersetzen sondern zum Wendepunkt
zu kommen nämlich auf dem Schlachtfeld
zu gewinnen wir haben alle Artillerie ja
vielen Dank
also ganz ehrlich wirklich nicht
um sicherzustellen das machwort nicht
nur eine Festung ist die Widerstand
leistet gegen die russische Armee
sondern damit die russische Armee sich
wirklich völlig zurückzieht brauchen wir
mehr
Kanonen und
genauso wie bei der Schlacht von
daatoga wird der Kampf um Waffen mutsche
den Weg bestimmen unseren Weg hin zu
Unabhängigkeit und Freiheit wenn ihre
Patriot Systeme den russischen Terror
gegen unsere Städte stoppen dann werden
die ukrainischen patriotischen alles tun
um unsere Freiheit zu verteidigen
unsere Städten nicht mit seiner
Artillerie erreicht versucht ist sie
durch
Raketenangriffe zu zerstören und darüber
hinaus hat Russland noch ein
verbündenden gefunden bei dieser Politik
des völkermortes nämlich den Iran die
tödlichen iranischen Drohnen die zu
Hunderten nach Russland geschickt wurden
wurden zu einer Bedrohung für unsere
kritische Infrastruktur
so hat ein Terrorist den anderen
gefunden es ist einfach nur eine Frage
der Zeit wenn die wieder zuschlagen auch
gegen ihre anderen Verbündeten wenn wir
sie jetzt nicht stoppen das müssen wir
tun
ich glaube
das ist keine Tabus geben sollte
unter uns in unserem Bündnis die Ukraine
haben niemals amerikanische Soldaten
aufgefordert auf unserem Land statt
unserer zu kämpfen ich versichere Ihnen
die ukrainischen Soldaten können perfekt
amerikanische Panzer und Flugzeuge
selbst bedienen
[Applaus]
finanzielle Hilfe ist natürlich auch von
kritischer Bedeutung und ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich bei Ihnen bedanken sowohl
für die finanzpakete die sie schon
geschnürt haben für uns und auch für
diejenige
über die sie noch entscheiden werden ihr
Geld ist kein Almosen es ist eine
Investition in die globale Sicherheit
und Demokratie mit der wir äußerst
verantwortungsvoll umgehen
[Applaus]
könnte seine Aggression beenden wirklich
wenn es das wollte aber Sie können
unseren Sieg beschleunigen das weiß ich
und es wird allen potenziellen
Aggressoren zeigen dass niemand Erfolg
haben kann wenn er nationale Grenzen
niederreißt und Gräueltaten gegen
Menschen gegen deren Willen begeht um
über sie zu herrschen es wäre naiver zu
warten das Russland Schritte
hinzufrieden unter
Russland gefällt es ein terroristischer
Staat zu sein die Russen sind immer noch
vergiftet durch den Krempel die
Wiederherstellung der internationalen
Rechtsordnung ist unsere gemeinsame
Aufgabe wir brauchen Frieden die Ukraine
hat ja auch schon Vorschläge
unterbreitet ich habe gerade unsere
friedensformen mit Präsident zu beiden
besprochen zehn Punkte die müssten wir
umsetzen für unsere gemeinsame
Sicherheit um die auch auf Jahrzehnte
hinaus zu garantieren und auch ein
Gipfeltreffen anzubohren und ich freue
mich dass Präsident beiden unsere
Friedensinitiative heute unterstützt hat
alle von Ihnen meine Damen und Herren
können bei der Umsetzung helfen um
sicherzustellen dass die amerikanische
Führungsrolle
solide bleibt von beiden Häusern des
Parlamentes
getragen wird und
fraktionsübergreifend ist
[Applaus]
sie können die Sanktionen noch
verstärken damit Russland fühlt wie
ruinös seine Aggression wirklich ist es
liegt in ihren Händen um uns zu
unterstützen alle vor Gericht zu ziehen
die diesen anlasslosen und
verbrecherischen Krieg begonnen haben
machen wir das auch
[Applaus]
ziehen wir den Terrorstaat zur
Verantwortung für seinen Terror und
seine Aggression er muss alle Schäden
ausgleichen die durch diesen Krieg
entstanden ist und zeigen wir der Welt
dass die Vereinigten Staaten hier sind
meine Damen und Herren meine Damen und
Herren Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner in
zwei Tagen werden wir Weihnachten feiern
vielleicht mit Kerzen nicht war das
romantischer ist nein
sondern weil es
kann Strom geben wird
Millionen werden
weder Heizung noch fließendes Wasser
haben
all das wird das Ergebnis der
russischen Raketen und Drohnen Angriffe
auf unsere Energie Infrastruktur zu sein
aber wir beklagen uns nicht wir urteilen
und vergleichen auch nicht wer ein
leichteres Leben hat
ihr Wohlstand ist das Ergebnis ihrer
nationalen Sicherheit das Ergebnis ihres
Kampfes für Unabhängigkeit und ihre
vielen Siege wir Ukrainer
unseren Krieg für Unabhängigkeit und
Freiheit mit Würde und Erfolg
[Applaus]
wir werden Weihnachten feiern
selbst wenn es keinen Strom gibt
das Licht unseres Glaubens das in uns
wohnt wird nicht erlöschen
[Applaus]
wenn die russischen Raketen uns
angreifen dann werden wir alles tun um
uns zu schützen wenn die uns angreifen
mit iranischen Drohnen und unsere
Menschen am
Heiligabend in
bombenschutzräume gehen müssen werden
die Ukraine trotzdem am Feiertags Tisch
sitzen und einander zu posten
[Musik]
haben alle denselben Wunsch auch
Millionen von Ukrainern wir alle wollen
das gleiche Sieg nur den Sieg
real ready wir haben schon eine starke
Ukraine aufgebaut mit starken Menschen
starke Armee und starken Institution
zusammen mit Ihnen wir haben nachhaltige
Sicherheitsgarantien für unser Land und
für die gesamte Welt und Europa
entwickelt zusammen mit Ihnen und
zusammen mit Ihnen werden wir sie
überall umsetzen und alle aufstellen
und in die Schranken verweisen die die
Freiheit in Frage stellen das wird die
Grundlage sein für den Schlüssel
Demokratie in Europa und der Welt
insgesamt
und während dieser ganz besonderen
Weihnachtszeit möchte ich nicht bei
Ihnen bedanken bei jedem von ihnen bei
jeder amerikanischen Familie die die
Wärme ihres Heims schätzte und wünscht
das andere Menschen dasselbe genießen
können ich bedanke bei Präsident weiten
an beiden Parteien im Senat und dem
Repräsentantenhaus für ihre unschätzbare
Unterstützung ich
bedanke mich bei ihren Städten und ihren
Bürgern die die Ukraine in diesem Jahr
unterstützt haben die unsere Menschen
aufgenommen haben die unsere nationale
Flagge
gehisst haben und die uns geholfen haben
herzlichen Dank an alle dieser dann
kommt von allen die jetzt an der Front
stehen und von allen die auf den Sieg
warten während ich heute hier stehe
denke ich an die Worte von Präsident
Franklin die Lana rustrote die sind
wirklich passend auch für diesen Moment
das amerikanische Volk hat das Recht auf
seiner Seite und wird kämpfen bis zum
absoluten Sieg
das ukrainische Volk wird auch
gewinnen
absolut
I know ich weiß alles hängt von uns ab
von den ukrainischen Streitkräften aber
so viel anderes hängt auch von der Welt
ab und so viel in der Welt hängt von
Ihnen ab
als ich gestern in bachmut war gaben wir
unsere Helden eine Flagge
die schlachtflagge die Flagge derjenigen
die die Ukraine verteidigen Europa und
die Welt und dabei ihr Leben riskieren
sie haben mich gebeten diese Flagge ihn
zu überreichen dem amerikanischen
Kongress den Mitglieder des
Repräsentanten Hauses und den Senatoren
deren Entscheidungen Millionen Menschen
leben retten kann
und insofern
treffen Sie diese Entscheidung möge
diese Flagge bei Ihnen bleiben meine
Damen und Herren diese Fahne ist das
Symbol unseres Sieges in diesem Krieg
wir hatten die Stellung wir kämpfen und
wir werden gewinnen denn wir sind geeint
Ukraine Amerika und die gesamte freie
Welt
[Applaus]
und wir sind noch einmal verbunden mit
dem Politikwissenschaftler Thomas Jäger
sie haben die rede jetzt mit uns
gemeinsam gehört als offene Frage zu
Beginn wie hat selensky das gemacht wie
fanden sie seinen Auftritt vor dem
US-Kongress
nun ist in einer schwierigen Lage
gewesen und im Vorfeld ist ja schon die
Parallele zur Rede von Churchill 1942
gezogen worden allerdings gibt es zwei
große Unterschiede zwischen den Reden
Churchill kam als die Vereinigten
Staaten schon in den Zweiten Weltkrieg
eingetreten warten und England hat sich
da Großbritannien damals sozusagen auf
Augenhöhe mit den USA gesehen und das
ist bei selenski eben anders er weiß die
USA werden nicht Kriegspartei werden und
er ist von der Unterstützung aus den
Vereinigten Staaten wesentlich abhängig
weil er anders die Waffen nicht bekommt
und das hat die Rede durchzogen die er
gleich wohl mit großem Selbstbewusstsein
vorgetragen hat als Präsident eines
Landes immer nicht zugetraut hat drei
Tage diesen Krieg zu überleben und das
nun im zehnten Monat seine Verteidigung
bewerkstelligt
wenn wir zum Schluss noch mal über das
Timing über den Zeitpunkt dieser Rede
sprechen
er traf auf einen amerikanischen
Präsidenten beiden und eben nicht auf
Trump er traf immer noch auf die Nancy
Palace im Repräsentantenhaus er traf auf
eine US-Bevölkerung kurz vor Weihnachten
die Herzen sind geöffneter sind weiter
als zu anderen Zeiten an all das hat er
appelliert er hat
amerikanische Präsidenten zitiert er ist
auf der amerikanische Geschichte
eingegangen er ist auf den Zweiten
Weltkrieg eingegangen er hat die ganze
Zeit versucht es auf ein höheres Niveau
zu heben und Weg zurück Rücken von dem
ausschließlichen Problem das sein Land
die Ukraine hat ich würde sagen eine
Kernaussage war dass er sagte ein
russischer Angriff gegen Verbündete sei
nur eine Frage der Zeit die Welt sei zu
sehr vernetzt als dass sich irgendjemand
sicher sein könne wie schätzen Sie das
ein
ja und das ist ja eine Bewertung die
viele Teilen erst vor wenigen Tagen
kamen aus Moldau eine entsprechende
Nachricht wenn man in die baltischen
Staaten zu Beginn des Krieges gehört hat
ist auch dort die Befürchtung groß
gewesen das Russland im Falle eines
Sieges über die Ukraine dann eben nicht
damit gut sein lässt sondern eben auch
weitere Territorien sich einverleiben
könnte und das ist etwas was ja auch
hinter dem russischen Vorhaben steht die
osteuropäischen Staaten von fremden
Truppen zu
die die von dort zu entfernen um
entsprechenden Druck aufzubauen insofern
stimmt dieses Argument denn wenn
Russland in diesem Krieg gegen die
Ukraine siegreich ist dann ist es nicht
zufrieden mit dem was es erreicht hat
das ist etwas das muss man gar nicht
hinein interpretieren das sagt die
russische Führung offen und das weiß man
selbstverständlich auch in Vereinigten
Staaten die USA unterstützen die Ukraine
ja nicht nur aus einem Impuls heraus
dass sich Staaten gegenseitig
unterstützen wenn sie angegriffen werden
sondern weil man in den USA weiß dass
die
europäische Staatenordnung gefährdet ist
wenn Russland den Krieg gewinnt man weiß
dass in den USA genauer und sieht das
schärfer als man das in Europa sieht der
ukrainische Präsident hat mit seinem
Auftritt in der vergangenen Nacht ja
auch Putin ein bisschen die Schau
gestohlen den Putin hat sich in Moskau
geäußert vor dem Verteidigungsrat und
hat dort sozusagen durchhalte Parolen
auf seine Art
verkündet und gesagt russland werde
nicht aufhören die Ukraine anzugreifen
und Russland sei sich sicher im
kommenden Jahr zu siegen
hat Putin sich auch in diesem Punkt
wieder verkalkuliert mit seinem Timing
ja das ist ja etwas was wir seit zehn
Monaten sehen es wird selbstverständlich
eben nicht nur an der Front gekämpft
sondern es gibt in beiden Staaten einen
Wettbewerb darüber wer das narrativ die
Interpretation in der internationalen
Öffentlichkeit bestimmt und hier ist es
eindeutig über die ganze Zeit hinweg das
Präsident selenski derjenige ist der
effektiver kommuniziert der klarer
kommuniziert und der Präsident Putin
völlig in die Defensive gerückt hat und
das was Präsident Putin gestern
verkünden wollte das ist völlig
untergegangen ob es seine eigenen
Truppen die er damit erreichen wollte
oder die russische Gesellschaft
überhaupt noch erreicht das ist schwer
zu beurteilen denn es ist ja nun äh eine
Rede gewesen die eben die Niederlagen
Russlands aus dem letzten Monaten
überhaupt nicht thematisiert hat und die
am Ende gesagt hat es läuft alles nach
Plan immer läuft alles Plan der Plan
wird erfüllt und am Ende wird es
Wunderwaffen geben
und selenski hat in Washington angemahnt
um sich dieser Wunderwaffen zu erwehren
braucht es eben noch eine lange lange
Unterstützung möglicherweise auch mit
Wunderwaffen des Westens oder
ja die Wunderwaffen des Westen gibt es
nicht und die in Russland gibt es auch
nicht das ist eine Erzählung die
Präsident Putin schon seit Jahren von
sich gibt aber richtig ist die Ukraine
hat in diesem Jahr in den letzten
Monaten teilweise in einer Woche mehr
Artillerie Geschosse verschossen als in
den USA im Monat produziert werden
können und da reden wir überhaupt nicht
von der munitionsproduktion in Europa wo
man die letzten zehn Monate wiederum
verschlafen hat und so getan hat als
hätte man irgendwelche vollen Lager die
ist gar nicht gab und das ist jetzt eben
auch eine Dimension des Krieges welche
Seite ist in der Lage die
rüstungsindustrieproduktion so schnell
Anzug Kurbeln das im der Schlacht die
geführt wird die Munition nicht ausgeht
aber das klingt jetzt tatsächlich wie
ein lächerliches Detail dass man das
kann doch nicht wahr sein oder
das ist so wenn Sie sehen dass die
Bundeswehr Munition für zwei Tage
vorhält entgegen aller NATO zu sagen die
gegeben worden sind und dass ich die
Bundesregierungen man darf nicht nur die
jetzige hierfür in Verantwortung nehmen
sondern die auch davor überhaupt nicht
darum gekümmert haben ob da irgendwelche
internationalen Verpflichtungen erfüllt
werden können wenn man bedenkt dass die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland sich
verpflichtet hat zehn Prozent zur NATO
ähm Streitkraft beizutragen was
überhaupt nicht erfüllt werden kann nein
man hat das schlicht nicht beachtet es
war einem egal andere Motive wollen wir
jetzt gar nicht thematisieren
wenn es nicht die völlig falsche Uhrzeit
wäre möchte man jetzt sagen na dann gute
Nacht ihnen aber Thomas Jäger vielen
vielen Dank dass Sie an diesem Morgen
zur Verfügung standen für unser Gespräch
und dass wir unsere Erfahrungen mit der
dem Auftritt von würde mir silence gehen
Washington austauschen konnten vielen
Dank nach Köln
ich danke Ihnen
ich habe es vorhin kurz erwähnt es ist
eben auch Weihnachten und in den
nächsten Tagen ja die Herzen der
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner sind ein
bisschen weiter geöffnet
möglicherweise ist der
sorgfältig inszenierte und
choreographierte Auftritt von selensky
ganz bewusst zu dieser Zeit eben gewählt
worden er hat es auch zu dieser Zeit
machen wollen weil er eben auch noch
diese Frau treffen wollte sehen wollte
weil er wusste wenn sie noch da ist dann
wird sein Auftritt mit Sicherheit ein
Erfolg werden
Nancy Palace auf der rechten Seite und
die amerikanische Vizepräsidentin auf
der linken Seite
vielleicht noch eine Bemerkung vielen
Dank gott schütze unsere mutigen Truppen
und Bürger gott segne die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika in alle Ewigkeit
frohe Weihnachten und ein glückliches
siegreiches neues dieses Jahr Slava
Ukraine
ja das war unsere kurze Sondersendung an
diesem Donnerstagmorgen
zum Besuch des ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski in Washington
sehen hier noch im US-Kongress mit
nancycelosy und Kamera Harris stehen und
er hat die ukrainische Fahne mitgebracht
auf der Soldaten unterschrieben haben
und jetzt im US-Kongress verbleiben wird